closing arguments in jesse smallett's
criminal trial are set to start later
this morning the former empire actor was
seen outside the courtroom yesterday
before finishing his second day of
testimony smallett again denied staging
a racist anti-gay attack on himself back
in january 2019. charlie damar is
covering this trial
returning to the stand tuesday jesse
smilet faced heated cross-examination by
prosecutors who wanted to know more
about his interactions with the two men
they say helped him stage an alleged
fake attack when asked about video of
him picking up abel and ola osindaro in
his car just days before the attack
smellet denied recruiting the brothers
to stage a hoax
simolette admitted that he drove past
the location where the alleged attack
would occur several times with both
those and darrell's in the car the actor
said there was nothing unusual about
them just driving around smilet was also
pressed about private social media
messages from the night of the reported
attack updating the brothers on the
status of his delayed flight and a call
from abel osendaro after he landed
osindaro testified that the call was to
confirm the time of the fake attack
smilet denied that ever happened on
tuesday
the jury is expected to get the case
today after closing arguments and will
determine if the 39-year-old is guilty
of six felony counts of disorderly
conduct for cbs morning's charlie demar
in chicago